at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also do personal
question now
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton it is very late
at night I am packing for an island
getaway why does that matter because it
reminds me of one of the sponsors for
today's podcast Mizanin man why because
the only dress shirt that I'm taking I
normally hate dress shirts is from
mizzen and Maine specifically the
Beckett blue gingham the reason are the
reasons I should say is because I can
throw it in my bag in a duffel not worry
about ironing not worry about any kind
of wrinkling and then throw it on where
it may be four or five nights out of
seven without washing it it won't smell
it's antimicrobial it is made of stretch
fabric sweat wicking athletic I could
wear it for a hike in between tanners if
I wanted to do it but I wouldn't do that
but mizzen and Maine has really
delivered on the all-around all-purpose
dress shirt they're fancy enough you can
fool people into thinking that you had
them custom tailored but they're also
rough enough and resilient enough that
you can toss them into the bottom of a
duffel bag or backpack pull it off and
put it on in a bathroom at a restaurant
let's say hundreds of pro athletes love
this brand people who don't fit well
into dress shirts otherwise like NFL
all-pro JJ Watt and the last time these
guys were featured on the show
Miz and Maine sold out of every item
that they featured so if you're
interested in checking them out I had to
recommend taking a look just go to Tim
vlog forward slash shirts and you can
see that one shirt that I'm packing that
I always pack the Becket blue gingham in
addition to a couple of my other
favorites and you can enter Tim that's
capital T I am at checkout for free
shipping if you use this code before
September 15th
that's 2017 to buy a dress shirt Mizanin
Maine will donate a brand new dress
shirt to the relief efforts in southern
Texas that's in addition to the thousand
shirts that are already being donated
through JJ Watts incredible efforts to
put or I should say weather
Houston the surrounding communities get
back on their feet so there you have it
check it out take a look even if it's
just to take a peek at this one shirt
the Beckett Tim blog forward slash
shirts again that's Tim dot blog forward
slash shirts this episode is brought to
you by kettle and Fire which makes some
of the best bone broth and certainly the
most convenient that I've ever found and
I have a big stack of them on my kitchen
counter right now I have one container
every morning and this first came highly
recommended to me by past podcast guests
such as Amelia Boone who's a four-time
world champion in world's toughest
mutter Spartan Race etc and dr. Dominic
D'Agostino The Incredible Hulk of
scientific research just check him out
too but there are a few things that make
kettle and fire special number one they
are the first shelf stable in other
words never frozen bone broth that uses
bones from 100% grass-fed organically
raised animals so you are what you eat
ate if that makes sense so it's very
important that you understand if you're
consuming animal protein what they
consumed they also use longer cook times
20 plus hours which means more collagen
and other nutrients for instance they
contain 19 times more collagen than one
of their close competitors and an
independent lab confirm this I'll leave
the competitor's name out of it because
I don't want to get sued but that's the
case and it is not frozen so thanks to
many millions of dollars of packaging
equipment their bone broth doesn't
require freezing or shipping with dry
ice so like I said it's just sitting on
my kitchen counter in these boxes and
then I can heat them up they're
basically ready to drink heat them up on
stovetop or in a microwave and you are
ready to rock and roll then you also get
a nice payload of glucosamine glycine
along with the gelatin and everything
else that I mentioned so check it out I
have been hugely pleased with this and
like I said I've been consuming it every
morning it gives you about once a 20
grams of protein which is a nice little
slow carb diet' boost if that's what
you're looking for and I'll typically
sip this out of a very large camping
coffee mug as I do some writing
or journaling so there you have it check
it out it's delicious I favor the
chicken but each to his own or her own
so check it out kettle and feiyr.com
forward slash to him and you can receive
20% off of your entire order take a look
kettle and feiyr.com forward slash Tim
this is Tim Berris welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I have
music on the mind it's a Friday as I
record this I've had way too much tea
and that gives me a little bit of
personality so let's jump into it this
episode of the podcast features stewart
copeland on twitter at Copeland
music who is considered one of the top
ten drummers of all times
certainly one of the greatest drummers
in rock and roll history he was one of
the founding members of the police has
been inducted into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame and is a Grammy
award-winning musician Stewart is
amazing I've spent time with him he
reminds me a bit of Doc in Back to the
Future it's Jo kids Marty
Chuck heads but I digress he is a
fantastic storyteller and a very very
well-spoken smart guy in this
conversation which is very wide-ranging
we delve into early lessons in surviving
and how to survive the music industry
why entrepreneurs never get a day off
and certainly any self-directed
musicians or creatives are entrepreneurs
in the sense of Imboden that to make
something from nothing how the police
developed the unique sound and the
decision that changed everything for
them and much more this interview comes
from my television show fearless fear
less less in quotation marks since your
goal is not to be fearless but to learn
to fear less and in this show I
interview world-class performers on
stage about how they've overcome doubt
conquered fear and made their toughest
decisions we recorded about 3 hours of
material only one was used for the TV
show so this podcast is almost entirely
new content that did not appear on TV
but I highly recommend a few things
number one you can watch the entire
first episode of fear
with illusionist and endurance artist
David Blaine and he does a bunch on
stage you can watch it all for free at
att.net forward slash fearless I'll
spelled out no parentheses so att.net
ford slash fearless so definitely check
that out and to see all episodes of this
new TV show you can use directv or you
can use the app at directv dot-com and
that's DirecTV now so you can check that
out dir e CTV calm and that is it for
now so let's move on please enjoy this
conversation with the one and only
stewart copeland welcome to fearless I'm
your host Tim Ferriss and on this stage
will be deconstructing world-class
performers of all different types to
uncover the specific tactics they've
used to overcome doubt tackle some of
their hardest decisions and ultimately
succeed on their own terms so imagine
yourself a founding member of one of the
most successful rock bands of all time
what happens when you break up for many
that might be the end of the story but
for my guest tonight it was just getting
started with no prior experience he went
on to score films for Francis Ford
Coppola and Oliver Stone composed for
ballet and opera and even take
pilgrimages to Africa where he played
drums with hungry lions I am not kidding
he's a founding member of the police a
member of the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
and for the last three decades he's been
one of Rolling Stones top ten drummers
of all time
please welcome musician master and
madman Stewart Copeland
so just like we're gonna get to the
backstory I was kidding with some of the
guys when we were doing all the research
that if I wrote a screenplay that
covered the arc of your life I think it
would get rejected or heavily edit as
being too unrealistic we're gonna get to
that it's just a fascinating story but
what was your mother's background
well she's British her job was analyzing
French and European train schedules and
so it's very if she was a spy but it was
in an office it was a bureaucratic
version of analyzing server for sorting
out bombing runs getting supplies and it
was called SOE and the ladies of the SOE
has almost all women by the way unsung
heroes and people are now writing books
about the SOE these women who fought
this kind of bureaucratic data war and
now data we all understand data but back
then it was kind of numbered and she met
my father they got married during the
war and um that's my parents she's a big
cheat when we went to Lebanon she was an
archaeologist and she wrote books as in
fact my mother very bookish in her books
or the kind of books that you don't read
in a bookstore the kind of books that
the people who write books that you read
uses research the first word in her book
you know one of our books is the the
second word is 14 syllables long great
but then it gets more and more
impenetrable as you go into it what was
it like growing up as the American in
Cairo or in Beirut well there were other
Americans too mostly oil families all
the kids at the American Community
School of Beirut rumored to the American
unities goes all the Aramco kids all the
families in Saudi Arabia are the
American families around they sent their
kids to this school in Beirut and in my
generation was the first generation
where the Saudi Arabians and the Gulf
Arabs with their new wealth began to
send their kids for a Western education
and so I in my age group
started to see Saudi princes in my class
and got to know them
one such was Osama bin Laden in your
class not in my class he would have been
of quite a billion years equal in that
school quite a few if I'd known him I
want to kick his ass yeah well I mean I
have to ask the dude say you met and
interacted with them no no no he was
years I voted after I got and I got it
well by the way yes I went back to
Beirut years later and it's all Arabic
now and they're all there the Lebanese
the most merket they're one of the
richest countries most developed
countries in the Middle East and they
rule in the Arab world
anybody who's running any of these
probably Lebanese and they have no real
resources they have huge civil strife a
huge ethnic tension but they've been
through their civil war and they've got
it resolved and just the Lebanese they
are all about education so the American
community school educating these kids to
go and conquer America which they do you
know there's a Lebanese ghetto here in
Los Angeles it's called Beverly Hills
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what do you want to be when you are a
kid I I can't remember any time before I
wasn't a musician and I don't remember
you know as seven or something like that
I just never ever when I was actually in
college I thought I don't actually want
to play music I want to organize it so I
you know I studied journalism and other
aspects of the entertainment industry
but the drums just kept the sirens
selling me back when did you leave the
Middle East
I left the Middle East and the mid-60s I
would have been 14 or 15 something like
that I was already playing in my high
school band and Beirut by that time and
I got to boarding school in England and
a couple things nobody had ever heard of
where I come from where do you come from
well Lebanon well where's that you know
the other thing was that I didn't
realize it but a lot of my vocabulary
wasn't English they speak in Beirut they
speak Arabic Renly's which is they
Arabic that the sophisticated Beirut EES
speak French but English American
English American was invading the
university was American the hospital
built by American missionaries the
Americans in the Middle East by the way
during my time were most part from My
Father
the Americans built hospitals and
universities and American money was
going into the Middle East from
Christian organizations for missionaries
and so Americans were known for no
strings attached
good stuff yeah you know because it was
the French and the British and the LD
Emperor imperial powers that had the bad
rap we soon earned a bad rap yeah but in
in those days Americans were much loved
what brought you to England why'd you
guys move well I was evacuated because
after the Philby thing it got hot and so
my father just suddenly had to get the
family out of Dodge Lebanon at that time
was always you know 1958 there was a
civil war there at that time while I was
there and it was bombs in the night we
had to fill the bathtub with water and
stock up with food and and so on and
there are sandbags in the streets and
now and actually in those days it was
put out by the United States Sixth Fleet
show up which is another reason I was
real proud to be American they showed up
in 1958
I think Eisenhower was president and
that was it
civil war over they just just for show
they landed a whole platoon or whatever
on the beach with the tanks and
everything in did a display of these
enormous ten okay let's all go back to
work now shall we you know and there was
no violence to out it was just a display
it was like a 4th of July exhibition
kind of thing these the kind of toys we
got to play with folks anybody any
questions
and because our as I said before because
our status there was very positive we
were loved there that we you know and
they there was an election coming up
they were very now will bore you with
the complicated politics but there was
an election coming up and there's a lot
of vegetation and so the Americans
showed up they had a peaceful election
they elected they've not the not
American guy actually them you know they
my father was glad but they elected
Shahab instead of the guy that the
Americans wanted but it was fine he did
a fine job and civil war over but it was
always there there had three major
religions there who had to share power
and the Christians ruled the country
then there is the Sunni and the Shia who
were at each other's throats as much
they all you know as a triangle and that
triangle with the influx of Palestinians
just couldn't hold and so civil war and
then there were there really awful civil
wars you know the same as what's going
on in Syria now they eventually blew
over and in Beirut Lebanon is probably
more able to withstand the Syrian war
next door because in Lebanon no no no
we've been there we're not the Sunnis
are fine this year
fine let's every you know everybody gets
to go back to work instead of the u.s.
Sixth Fleet showing up the civil the
civil war in Syria next door and their
own history means they're not about to
pick a fight anytime soon yeah before I
was born in Syria wherever the family
was living before I was born my mother
was pregnant with my brother Ian comes
up in conversation a lot and they had a
problem with their general who was they
depart they you know their dictator was
running the place of a fuzzy al-shabaab
or whatever his name was and he was you
know starting to get starting to talk to
the Rooskies and so on and so you gotta
get rid of this guy and so they figured
out this is my father's idea that I tell
you what why don't we have a Renta mob
go an attack an American diplomats house
a rental of ours and so and then then
the our
our new Colonel that we've been shining
up he can get the soldiers out to go and
put down this riot and while the
soldiers are out they can take over the
radio station and the palace and that's
how they did it in those days and he the
colonel who took over the palace thought
he was working against American
interests but in fact the other Colonel
Heather - undisclosed was the actual guy
and so his system was getting other
people to do the work dirty work but
okay so this attack happens on the
family home the Copeland family home in
Damascus Syria and there lay - my
father's on the phone to Beirut and they
show up oh great great bang oh no they
got guns that's not you know in a bank
bank and the famous line that he had
which is our family thing is uh he says
I'm gonna have to hang up now they're
shooting at me personally I never even
believed these stories because it was my
dad telling him and he used to say never
let the facts ruin a good story but the
history books are being written now
about that period of my father's in
there oh my god and according to the
books and I didn't realize this until I
found in the family archives some you
know newspaper clippings about it he
chased him off with a gun he had a gun
my father had a handgun I never saw him
with a gun or he you know Alabama kid
chases out bandits with a handgun and
there were in one of the Persian rugs
there bullet holes and my sister's got
that rug because during those days the
the diplomatic wives and all the wives
would go to Iran our Persia as it was
known and buy all this incredible stuff
so I have in my studio these Persian
rugs that are older than I am they've
been in the family longer than iron and
in fact another little digression the
patterns on those Persian rugs with
these strangely geometric and yet curved
lines and everything like that and now I
was crawling around face-first on those
rugs from the age of zero all the way up
and I just looked at those rugs the
other day and I realized that pad
is my music that my music is exactly
that the way it's a combination of
symmetry and wild abandon the way the
different colors interact with each
other I realize it was like printed
without his nose first face first in
these Persian rugs so I'm gonna dial
this back a little bit to college how'd
you choose where to go to college how
did you end up going where you did ah
well I was a draftable American in spite
of my pride in my country we were
fighting a war in Vietnam at the time
for which my brother had volunteered my
brother Ian the heroic brother actually
not only did he have a motorcycle in
high school but he went to Vietnam he
volunteered he came back and decorated
hero he you know I can't you know
battalion Citation Presidential Citation
Purple Heart Bronze Star he found
himself you know and he came back and
became an agent never saw a gun for the
rest of his life but he started he was a
wild kid who discovered that and he came
back and when he came back he was spat
on and reviled and it was a tragedy of
the Vietnam War how the American people
sought because we were afraid that we
could be sent out wasn't voluntary those
weren't volunteers over there that could
be me and he did volunteer and he was
fine until the Gulf War the first Gulf
War and when he heard the crackle of the
radios the thump-thump thump-thump of
the helicopters it came back and it
almost did he had a psychosis for it and
then when the soldiers came home as
conquering heroes he you know that was
that that's what how he should have been
treated every single one of the soldiers
in his platoon ended up his heroin
addicts they didn't make it none of them
made it he died of Agent Orange a few
years ago taken by melanoma that's how
the Vietnam War generation was treated
and I didn't want any part of that
personally and by the time I came along
I'm at the end of the baby boom and by
the time I got to college there were
plenty built all these colleges
cassadee for the baby-boom time i came
along and kind of weirded out of it so
it's easy for me to get into college you
know there's all this space but how the
hell did we get there how did you end up
going to college okay so then we had to
draw a lottery system everybody senators
kids everybody was getting drafted then
so they had a lottery system whatever
your birth date you take your date out
of a they pull the dates out of a hat
okay September 27th that's one okay
January 18 that's two okay April 9
that's three and you go down to all the
365 days of the year and you get a
number - July 16 and depending on what
state you were in
they had a quota Alabama had a quota of
if you're in Alabama and you registered
to vote in Alabama and your number was
47 you're drafted if your number was
high 200 or above you're probably safe
well the draft board for people who
turned 18 outside of America was zero
they had his quota of zero so as long as
I didn't come to America I was legally
not drafted I registered and I
everything but then I got my number 287
and then it was a so then I continued my
university education in America
Berkeley Berkeley Berkeley why did you
choose Berkeley because I'd outgrown the
small school that I was at and I wanted
to go to a big school with 40,000
students and learn from you know Nobel
winners and so on just felt like a
bigger badder place it's a great school
it's right in my backyard uh don't tell
me about and tell us about the college
event that the tip sheet now you're
getting okay now you have found a
question for which I'm gonna have to
make up material and it's been I don't
mean by by making it up I mean like
that's a question I've never answered
before all right
Mazel Tov thank you College event was an
idea of my older brother miles who was
the the business man of the family and
basically I called up all the colleges
around the
and I said tell me about what concerts
you put on how much did you spend Frank
Zappa how much did he cost Janis Joplin
how much did he pay how'd they go down
how did this think of it and they just
send me back their report of the gig and
I printed it onto what was called a tip
sheet it's just information just data
and I would send it to all the colleges
in the West so they could see the you
know UC Santa Barbara can see that UCLA
paid Frank top you know ten thousand
dollars they trashed the dressing rooms
and or whatever and so the colleges
could use this as a data sheet and I
sold advertising to the record companies
and so on and so forth that was a little
business venture and then that drumming
it was just while I was in like second
or third edition then I'd call it
calling up selling the stuff and getting
the letters and the college people sent
all I had to do is print their letters
about what agent ripped them off and
didn't treat them on that agent the guy
who deals with universities they have a
lot of money these colleges oh my god
and so suddenly I had power power but it
was all going great until that drumming
thing and there was a band over in
London needed a drummer and it was
summer so I went over to the London to
play in a band and never came back
what was the what were the most
important lessons that you took from
putting the other that tip sheet that
you have to do it yourself
was the main thing and you have to think
of everything and there's the
entrepreneur unlike a job holder doesn't
get a day off and my you know roommate
you know people in the in their building
they had jobs and they knew when they go
to work and they knew when they come
home and they got their check and but
they have to go to work as an
entrepreneur you don't have to go to
work you're always working and you you
can never not be at work and so you know
of my sins I have seven children and my
son's you know for instance just take
two for instance one is an entrepreneur
filmmaker has a band he's just he's
always pick
the phone he's hustle-bustle and the
other has a nine-to-five job they are
both happy as clams the nine-to-fiver he
can't imagine what it's like and then 6
o'clock he gets into his car he is free
his life just as it belongs to him he
can watch TV and have friends and go at
the dinner he just lives a great life
next morning he gets up goes to work
works like hell enjoys his job and then
Jordan he would not be able to thrive
under those conditions and what do you
mean I have to get up you know it's more
of a question no no no you can't go to
bed yeah I remember being told once I
said if you work diligently eight hours
a day for perhaps 10 years then you can
get promoted to boss and work 12 hours
yes that's exactly when the punk bands
in London in 1977 desired to play reggae
because it was you know for punk bands
the only form of chill was dub reggae
which is still hostile still pissed off
but chill and so there was no such thing
as chill punk music you just can't slow
it down and you know and so that the the
punk rockers would chill to dub reggae
which meant that I could fall right into
that topper headon to his credit he
figured out let's see the backbeat
doesn't go in two and four so he's
sitting there in his drums and he had to
learn how to do it and he could do it I
already could do it and so we developed
that sound in the police which is kind
of important and we didn't actually play
reggae strictly the way it comes out of
Jamaica we did a kind of own thing to it
but it was elemental it wasn't learning
it the way topper had do it just was
that secret weapon that I got from my
friends in Lebanon
so I call Stingo and I say so Annie
wants to join the band
he's like Fanta he's in that said no no
brainer what are we waiting for
and I think dude calm down calm down we
can't afford it he's a you know I have
to explain to Andi there's no record
company
I'm the record company you know illegal
records you know I printed them myself
sting and I put the records into the
bags ourselves and I with lettre said I
did the artwork myself and I called up
the stores my son we got
I'm the record company management I'm
the manager to an agent I'm booking the
gigs to rody
that's you and so we you know I'm really
flattered but you're gonna leave after
two weeks you know we can't you know
you're you know you got a life you got
expenses you know and he insisted he
said no no I'm canning all my sessions I
want to be in the band he had played
with sock machine or burden the animals
that you know he had a list of credits
as long as your arm but he didn't want
to be a side man anyone to be in the
band and to be for the band to be his
band and of course I'm gonna get rid of
that other guitarist you know that right
but I say sure sure sure I didn't think
about that we actually did play a couple
of shows with two guitars but so he
insisted and so and by this time sting
going not know he's an actual musician
he's in the band I'm gonna calm down
and finally you know it's I think he's
in awe right now you know okay
so Andy's in the band and immediately
Andy has deep musical training I didn't
have to show him an E chord or a D or an
a chord he knows he flattens 7th carry
them you know you know he really and as
soon as him and sting put their heads
together out of nowhere
sting writes a song right as a result of
Andy joining the group there was another
surprise in store for us all which was
that in our punk band the singing was
dance thing could do that and that's all
I ever heard him do because that's what
we did and that kind that
genre was all shouting but we had one
last Andy Summers gig to do he said look
I've got one last gig this guy in
Germany and I'm gonna go over and by way
he needs a drummer so you got a gig too
so dandy and I went over to Germany with
Everhard churner this high-concept thing
where he's got jazz saxophone
he's got Liz areum he's got a ballet
dancer and a punk group yeah
and for a punk group you know actually
you know we got a buddy he plays bass
why don't we bring him over to church
they brought suit so the three of us are
there as the punk group is a part of
this multi you know mix and match kind
of show and the jazz singer the
obligatory American jazz singer the jazz
singer chick and she had the shoulder
down she's out of tune and liked it that
way the jazz out of tune she's a punk
man one day so but long story short we
the first show we were not unprepared we
you know the the all kinds of bedlam and
craziness and we got the first show or
do we do you know how we're gonna finish
the set at one point she slinks off she
does her this links off like that and
there's the mic stand then there we are
and we're not quite sure what what to do
next base fire walks up to the
microphone in the sound out of his mouth
a keening wailing sound that was soaring
high with the stars with a pain and a
yearning and a growing feeling of the
cosmos coming down to take us away in
the heart of this wave and Andy and I
can [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
and so the police was born well with two
things I didn't know he could write
songs and I didn't know he could sing
like that and it was sort of Andy who
made it all the the whole thing come
together the cocktail come together so
at the police how did you decide on
certain visual aspects of the band or
other stylistic decisions like the
bleached blond hair for instance well we
would never be caught dead discussing
such matters
the bleached blond hair came from the
fact that Sting's wife was an actress
she had an agent she took one look at
her clients husband and said that guy
belongs in front of a camera and she
would send him for modeling jobs and in
advertising and so on and he would get
every gig and one day they wanted a punk
band for a Wrigley's chewing gum
commercial and so they called you know
he got the gig and said well I have a
punk band I am myself a punk
so they got Andy and I out there as well
but they didn't think we looks gnarly
enough I know let's peroxide their hair
and so that the the wardrobe people just
like the ladies you got back there they
made us look the part and we looked at
each other say that's kind of cool
and so we got our blonde look from a
Wrigley's chewing gum from her
somewhere if they add didn't run I guess
it didn't test well or something and
somewhere in a vault somewhere is that
add of the three blood heads blonde for
the first time I actually am blonde okay
this is real actually okay grey but I'm
blonde too but alas the locust sick my
hair common cause of male pattern
baldness
you know Stingo and I music fulfills a
different purpose in our lives for me
its celebration it's a party and for
sting perhaps it's more of a escape you
know a peaceful beautiful place that he
can go to and those two things when we
were codependent we are the differences
between us really filled gaps and so is
very synergistic that as we you know the
first two albums were recorded with that
you know the first album it was just us
in the studio and we got in there and we
recorded an album in 20 minutes and then
the second album was after we start to
get somewhere in America and we've been
playing and we're getting great reviews
and burning down the house night after
night and we're feeling really great and
they say you have your whole life to
write your first album in six months to
write your second and so there we're
back in the studio and you know we got
half an album or at the material but we
got to get a new album and so that
second album we just came up with it we
were full of ourselves were you know we
were validated by you know we we know
that we're the coolest so we had
confidence and our second album just was
all creativity had a bunch of hits on
that record too so the third album we're
going into the studio and now we are not
just us anymore this was the beginning
of the police becoming something that
isn't our just our little thing anymore
it's bigger than us and there's a
momentum there there's a record company
that's counting on hits and we were
there in Holland in fact recording the
third albums in yeah
and the record company are actually in
the studio is that a hit no I think the
other ones hit was like commerce was in
the room with us and it really bummed us
out kind of like that but we were still
hadn't had a buzz going and it was us
against the world the next two albums
which we recorded in Montserrat in the
Caribbean far far away twelve hours from
the nearest record company executive and
there was just the three of us and by
now we were not so codependent but when
it comes to music I kind of like working
with an orchestra and by the way I write
music for 60-piece orchestra they don't
talk back I put every note and how they
play it on the thing that piccolo player
has been playing piccolo his whole
career but he's gonna play exactly what
I put on the page and it's not da da da
da da da Dada da da with a little
diminuendo at the end with articulate
the you know staccato the third note and
then the the you know the slur over in I
put on the page in ink in Italian
exactly in 60 guys and that's how it
works
and guess what sting likes to do that
too and he's real good at it and he has
kind of a track record of being
successful at it
but what he wants to do is kind of
different from what I want to do the
purpose of music for him has a different
purpose for me and and we came together
for the reunion tour and it was so hard
for us to make the pieces fit back
together because guess what 20 years ago
by and we'd grown and I had lost I'd
gotten out of the habit of the bass
player turning around telling me
anything you know and he'd gotten out of
the habit of this world war 3 going
behind his left shoulder and he comes
over to well maybe not you know with the
best of intentions you know I'm sure
sting looks at the mirror every morning
says ok today I'm gonna let Stuart be
Stuart yeah
and I would look at the mirror in the
morning anything he wants I will be
there for him
any scintilla of Newt I will listen and
I will do my best to remember what he
told me and try you know and that gets
us through the first hour of rehearsal
this is the thing about Francis Coppola
as he can spot Talent yeah and his you
know very different from somebody like
Oliver Stone for whom I've scored as
well who's Stone himself owns every
frame every aspect of the film comes
from his creativity and that's what he
does you know he doesn't want people
clever ideas he wants people who are
clever at carrying out his ideas and
fortunately he's got really great ideas
so Francis has a different technique he
finds people that have the talent and he
just gives them a long lead and says you
just go for it you take it take it I
want to see what do you come up with and
that was a good relationship what did
what was different about the idea that
you presented for the material I'll give
you a clue which was the his people has
produced kept saying when's the scoring
date date I've been in the studio for a
month what I mean date you know the way
they used to do films was there to have
a date and on the date they show up with
the orchestra and they record the music
on that day and that's the that's the
recording session I don't do it like
that I am in the studio by myself and I
play a little bit of drums then I add
some guitar and then I fiddle around
over here and I'm working I'm building
it like you make a record and I was in
that was just completely an alien
exercise I mean the people come down and
they said this is kind of interesting
and but there was the moment when
Francis did turn around so this all
sounds really fantastic and all of his
old guy is his crew that he'd been
working with forever
they're all think wow this is really
different on everything like that but it
kind of works that's the crazy but it
kind of works you know and but it did
turn on say I want strings you know I
need some strings and I'm going oh [ __ ]
he's gonna hire some string schlocky guy
Francis you're so right you need strings
I'm gonna fix up some nice strings like
strings you know nice strings strings
and so I call up the contractors to send
me some strings
okay sure fine how many strings I don't
know how many strings is strings send me
some strings you know and so these I
think was maybe 14 and 15 guys showed up
you know strings and now they arrive and
usually a recording session the guitar
shows up and you booked him for the
afternoon then he comes in with his 10
guitars in a couple amps with a bunch of
pedals and he's okay so the first thing
it's just kind of a gue dandy and then
when it comes to that shout okay there's
a shop of his name is you know I'm Matt
Dillon is called you know that kid with
a bandana okay on the shot I'm just kind
of hitting a kind of thing there and
then kind of pull back a little bit
there and then you know and you're
talking to like that and that's the way
you work in the guy oh cool how about
this maybe how about that try that strat
account you know you talk and it's an
interaction in between the two of you
collaborate you get a turn so the
strings arrive a lot of them and so I go
out to do my thing hey guys it's great
to have you here and as movies kind of
an art movie and you know the first song
it's kind of thinking it because then
when you see the guy with a bandana it
just kind of goes a little like like
that
and I'm talking and I'm talking of that
and they're looking kind of more and
more uncomfortable and eventually one of
them says uh maestro do you want us to
play what the music on the page here or
whatever the [ __ ] you're talking about
play the page
and so they do invite the page by the
way in this case was footballs what they
call its whole notes
yeah yeah you know I didn't know how to
write it I don't know how to write that
music at that time so it's just the
chords that I was playing myself
bling-bling here stop the tape okay roll
tape bling and you're bought and put
that on a chart so that that's the top
no no okay we'll give that the violin
and violin tuned viola and you know and
I had an arranger put it on the page you
know then I didn't study Dean I was a
you know a music major in college so I
could read it but I hadn't seen a sheet
of music in 20 years in rock and roll
there are no sheets of music it just
this is not part of the vocabulary but
here were these string players a section
answer they have these footballs and
they say well look it's all footballs
could we just listen trun it down
everybody want you what to do okay cool
okay roll tape and they play and they
were done in like half an hour they just
played what was on the page you know I
didn't need to talk to him at all they
just play it was on the page and they
played it and they were done you know
you know after the guitarist guy he's
there all afternoon you're trying stuff
these guys it's on the page they play it
exactly and they're done you mean all I
got to do is figure it out and do the
homework put it on the stand and they
play it so 20 years later I've you know
I've done maybe 40 50 films TV
commercials and all the stuff and you
use orcs for a lot and pretty soon I got
I learned how to write that little bit a
little bit a little you know
and now fancy stuff and the best part of
it is that it's about the helmet with
with a band you think on your feet and
it's an interaction musicians of the ear
musicians are divided at Birth into two
categories musicians of the ear and
musicians of the eye musicians of the
ear where I come from yeah they're
connected to music by the ear they're
staring off in space and they just know
when eight bars are up and they know
where to listen for the
and they're part of that groove and
they're connected with their ear
musicians of the I read a chart and they
their fingers follow what their eyes
tell them to play and even the rhythm
comes from the conductor a visual cue
the conductor's baton their eyes connect
them to the music and the musicians of
ear they just make that [ __ ] up it's
it's a collaborative a it's
improvisational they know that it's EA
and D but how you gonna hit that e how
you gonna which in version of a you know
and so there's you know it's the it's a
collaboration you work it out together
takes forever but in orchestral music
you put it on the page and they will
play it and like I said before it's not
just dad I got uh its Dada Dada and you
know that you put that [ __ ] you have to
put all that shape on the page and if
you do 60 guys and that guy over there
on the double bass and that guy way over
there on second violin there 30 40 feet
away from each other but each of them
has their own book with only their own
part and if they follow exactly what's
on the page and execute it beautifully
then they all all 60 of them become the
mighty Chicago Symphony and that's where
their ego lies not from I'm gonna
express myself on this part here
goddammit even though I'm the third
chair second violin know their ego their
pride in their work comes from these
corporate identity of the Magnificent
orchestra of which they are part and by
the way they're playing Mendelssohn and
Brahms and really really good music and
the best of the best of the best that is
withstood the test of time so there's
two completely different musical
universes and I love jamming with guys
who come over to my studio and we Jam
let me just make it up as we go along
but I also love to do that homework and
get it on the page and conceive of every
aspect of it where the swell is where
the surge the ebb and the flow in that
violin let go up to there and he gets up
high like that in the trumpet takes it
over and goes ba boom on the low brass
oh you know that's just really a lot of
fun to conceive of that stuff and then
you're going you sit with the orchestra
and they play it and without debate and
the first time it sounds a little creaky
the second time it's like wow and then
by show time it's really good fun to
play that stuff I like this question
this is from James stabs Facebook he's
one of the few rock drummers that plays
traditional grip how did he come to play
that way so maybe you could also explain
to people what this means well in olden
times the snare drum was a military
instrument for marching and to March
with a in the snare drums with that deep
cylinder like this and that deep and to
March with it like this is kind of hard
so what they do they turn on its side so
that the drum is like that and you can
still March which means to hit the drum
like this is kind of a problem so how
about this hand hold the stick like that
and you create the drum is at this angle
and now your sticks can go like that
because that whereas this would be a
problem that's where it came from okay
when they took the snare drum and put it
on a drum set and created the trap set
probably down in New Orleans or
somewhere wherever they whoever had the
idea of assembling a bunch of drums and
the trap set the snare drum was you know
the technique of playing it still was
this you know both hands are not the
same this is called match grip this is
called Orthodox it's old-school and just
the practitioners would set up this
newly invented contraption and have the
snare drum at that angle okay
years go by and I learned from that from
you know Buddy Rich and the Gene Krupa
style the my father as soon as he
spotted me as a musician had me in
lessons which meant Orthodox somewhat
paradiddles and flama diddles and all
the rudiments and everything with this
technique and then nowadays a drummer
can set up the drums of anyhow he darn
well wants and he has it logically
flat and the tom-toms logically like
that in what's this for so he plays like
this nowadays nowadays drummers all play
matchstick rip it makes perfect sense
now in my opinion this is a bigger digit
than this there's bigger muscles here so
what I want to get that
backbeat look out baby this hammer is
coming down with this thumb to bring it
down and it just seems like a more
stronger thing I don't know it's not
matched and so you learn to make it so
the effect is the same but different
mechanics in each hand
glad you asked the next one is from
Masood Kahn we don't have to do ten but
he asked the ten top ten albums you take
to another planet let's just say three
albums the desert well any Hendrix album
but probably the double one because it's
a double one which would be the third
one
accessed no not access was the third one
boutique child or visited double album
pick all the naked girls on bicycles
I'll go google it later anyhow that's
one I'm not a huge Beatles fan but I
would probably take either the white
album or Sergeant Pepper just cuz the
variety if we're gonna be stuck on that
island for a long time we meet some
variety and probably some blues just
because it makes me feel good but then
again I could play blues myself no I
wouldn't take a blues record I don't
know some classical some Stravinsky
probably rights of spring I hope
protrusion scheme and if you're out of
the running if you had to combine so say
three drummers alive or dead into your
to the perfect super drummer who would
they be
and why I would take the majesty of John
Bonham he achieved with very few drum
strokes very size Bach don't bone but it
just sounds like a mountain and
everybody nobody has gotten there
figured out how to make a drumset sound
so huge and it's the economy and it's
the way he hits the drum just some magic
about the way he played created sighs
just hugeness then I would take
god I'm terrible with names James
Brown's drummer Stubblefield stubble
anyone here anyone cried stubble field
for funk because we got a dance you know
and he's not a star guy but just give me
some of that and so we're all be dancing
and those pudendal will be you know
doing what they do uh and then I would
take Mitch Mitchell for a technique or
Buddy Rich what about the technique just
the effervescence the the lively spark
of either it be tough between I mean
Buddy Rich is the number he is the
absolute top got whether you like his
music or not there's nobody he's been
able to achieve just the manual
dexterity let alone the artistry and
everything else I mean he really is in
the class of his own Mitch Mitchell is
up there as well but he had he was music
was more fun and more effervescent and
and sauce I'd probably take John Bonham
Clyde Stubblefield and and Mitch
Mitchell so we saw you tearing it up in
the first video that we showed this next
question is from I am Keith Andrew on
Twitter what weaknesses in your playing
or writing or composing bug you and are
you fighting to overcome how do you
fight them arthritis writers yeah and
right now I play with an orchestra and
my drums are designed to play to
accompany amplified instruments which
can be any amount of volume you know
it's the dynamic and range of the rock
and roll drummer goes from seven to
twelve guitar it's only go to eleven and
drummers and by the way we don't do it
by turning a little knob we do it by
hitman and in the orchestra the
orchestra feels very loud but is in fact
a quarter of the volume of a rock band
when you go to a concert and you see in
order to play it feels emotionally
really big but physics wise it's
actually much more quiet and so you have
the huge orchestra and you put the
drummer there crack and big orchestras
gone there toast you can't hear them
nothing because the drums are so low
the biggest challenge has been to play
quietly on AI now after years of playing
with orchestras and working on it and
and and I practice with the music barely
audible so I I can't accompany it unless
I get it down there and a couple things
first of all less work
second of all the drum sound so much
better
third of all all kinds of finesse of
technique that I learned as a kid but
never could use in rock and roll they
just have we never hear the you know a
rough or a drag you know you can't hear
them in rock n roll now you can so they
sound great cool technique less work and
so learning how to play that quietly I
can now play a faun drum set my drum set
designed for the aforementioned
cacophony and there's a violin solo that
I wrote a nice little violin solo and
she's 30 feet away and I'm not there and
I can now play so quietly that I can
hear her and soak in the audience you
know and that that's an achievement is
the is we mentioned arthritis is that
a-- is that a real issue that you're
contending absolutely yeah there there
there and there
why my thought how do you how do you
deal with that well I find that if I you
know I don't look at my drums until I've
got a show coming up and this year I've
had shows coming up all year so I've
been in shape and so I have to start up
it's like Rocky you know I start slow
and I work it up and I'd have little
things like that to get you know and I
find that when I get fit to play and I'm
up to speed the arthritis goes away and
it doesn't return until I walk away from
the drums and I don't even look at them
until next time I have to and then the
arthritis creeps back in opening the
door if it's locked a locked door ah man
that's hurts you know and and I think
darn this is really inconvenient for
what I do but in fact when I start
playing drums when I get fit you know
it's not a problem do you do anything
else for self care of the hands or that
uh yeah there's the stretches I have a
thing that I got in China which is like
a little pointy soft wooden thing that I
just sort of massage
the muscles and like I say that there's
quite a fetish I'm pretty familiar with
the structure of the hand but there's
ten bones there and like all this really
complicated but you I'm pretty into
making it work and playing it about
volume this just isn't the stress that
it is that high volume so this might be
related but next question is from Tinker
Coffee Co at - your coffee Co what's the
most technical but underappreciated
skill for a drummer to possess I would
say that quiet thing quite because I
have drummers who have that range
dynamic range of seven to twelve and
that's just really hard work you know my
buddy fisherman in fish he's really
quiet he's been doing that all and I saw
that guy and you know you see them from
the front and it's blazing cuz there's a
fifty billion watt PA system to make it
louder he doesn't need to make it louder
yeah and so the scientist said watching
and he's just comfy he's hardly breaking
a sweat I'm gonna do that you know and
playing quietly that's the most
unappreciated technique that I would say
to answer that question
all right well given that you're at your
so you're talking sort of categories are
the do not discuss list for dinner
conversation if you were to give a TED
talk let's say or some high profile talk
20 minutes long but you couldn't talk
about music couldn't talk about drumming
nothing that you're known for but maybe
some secret obsession or thing that you
study on the weekends or in the evenings
or anything for that matter what would
you talk about Old Testament theology
Old Testament theology yeah all right
well Laura I grew up in the Holy Land
and they're still arguing about it now
to this day whose is it and which
religion prevails and it turns out that
the three religions fighting most
vociferously over that piece of real
estate are the same religion they come
from the same book and the Old Testament
is that book and the Old Testament is
unique because I also love Egyptian
history you know I think Moses was a
jackass you know the
the Egyptian history was a beautiful
beautiful thing as described in the Old
Testament you know the Egyptians were
great people with great values and
beautiful culture but the people who
wrote the Old Testament didn't think so
so the Egyptians described their enemies
in these pejorative terms and in turn
are described by the Israelites in these
pejorative terms as fascinating because
in the Egyptian history there was no
plagues
there was no Moses there was no Exodus
and so obviously the Exodus and the
events referred to in the Old Testament
there's something happened historically
to create what became these stories you
know there's got to be an origin to
these stories which pharaoh was that
which part of Egyptian history was that
you know traditionally it's Ramsey - you
know the big one just because he's the
biggest but it wasn't then you figure
out they're these different chronologies
there's the archaeology or let's start
with the Old Testament which says that a
thousand years ago Moses did this so
many thousand your soul Solomon did that
and there's a chronology then there's
the Egyptian chronology which has its
list of Kings and it's not measured in
nineteen twenty seven ninety there is
like this King in the third year of
Kings son a crib the second and it's
like you have to know how many and they
there's that chronology then there's the
archaeology the strata of Jericho for
instance tells us that there was no
burning down of Jericho when the Bible
says that they came the cat you know
they came and burned down Jericho didn't
happen folks Jericho has been burnt but
not when the Bible says it did a couple
three thousand years early well okay
well let's pull that Bible kranji down
pull this one up so that that matches
now well then we got a problem with the
Egyptian chronology so we stretched that
that [ __ ] you know in the period of
Solomon there are no great architectural
masterpieces or anything to denote a
great Kingdom during the time of Solomon
doesn't mean he didn't exist it means
that the chronology of when the Bible
said he exists might be a little
inaccurate so you like that's what I can
find
endlessly fascinating okay okay I know I
know I know
I know I lost you I totally lost you
there for a minute but I'm gonna bring
you back okay over in the west side of
Los Angeles there's all these private
schools where all those fancy folks send
our kids and there's only a few of us
all us fancy folks send our kids and
they have these school gala fundraising
events where they raise money is if they
need to raise money they have this gala
event and they have you know all the
bands you know and you know we got all
you know the dads there's gonna be some
rock stars in there and so they have you
know I call what I call The Grateful dad
which is the school band of whoo
whatever dads are in that school and you
know one of the schools here are
Wildwood the school the Grateful dad was
Stephen Stills gene Simmons me Berkeley
[Music]
Chavez bark Lee miles in a wheelchair
kind of a rap for Indiana and Bob Dylan
was supposed to be there but he bailed
so that's the bad gene Simmons Stephen
Stills and me okay that's pretty
disparate well we figure out a show we
play for all the feds a-- okay turns out
that gene simmons is a student of Old
Testament theology so they're at this
event where we're playing all this stuff
like there's the bass player of kiss and
the drummer of police backstage arguing
about which prophet no zebediah was not
so you're clearly a very well-read guy
are there any quotes is there a quote or
quotes that you either live your life by
or think of often don't worry be happy
all right so and by the way by the way
that's just the first thing right and
thank you for that nice polite applause
Oh what the [ __ ] does that mean what use
is that don't worry be happy as if is
that pill for that some good advice but
it is good advice it's kind of facile so
we can also come back to that one if
anything if any if there's someone who
is particularly quotable in your mind in
a way that is impacted you maybe that's
another way to tackle it you know for me
it would be a Seneca maybe an emerson
wow that's sophisticated well I mean
Seneca no I'll show you how
unsophisticated I am so from Long Island
I thought Seneca was and there is
another Seneca in fairness but a Native
American elder for the longest I was
like this guy's the best quote ever that
was like oh wait he's a Roman has been
dead for 2,000 years I thought that was
a football team or a city and it is a
lot of things Seneca has been used for a
lot of labeling if you were saying
giving advice to a young musician very
capable musician who's getting ready for
their first when they perceived to be
big gig and they're just all nerves they
are they feel like they're gonna bomb it
in this case by the way a presenter of a
television could have been me what
invite what advice would you get that
person relax relax
how take that as your living room it's
well that particular thing there's a
bunch of specific to that challenge
which is that there are audiences on
your side you're you're you're you walk
out on stage as a total success and it's
yours to throw away and it's really hard
to throw away you know so relax
assume
that you're blowing everybody away and
everything else will take care of itself
you know when I was young I used to
think that I gotta get myself out to go
on stage and I gotta go out but in fact
that's the dissipation of the energy you
know there was that film whiplash where
the kid is trying to get better and he
goes back to woodshed they show him in
the woodshed
that's the one thing they got wrong yeah
to get better you don't grow like that
you go like that you know calmly and the
more relaxed you can be the more energy
the more ferocity you can achieve by
being relaxed you know definitely
mass-murderer is best delivered cold any
act of violence has more aggression and
violence if it's done calmly well you
also see this in athletics right amazing
it really that's kind of a nervous evil
laugh chorus of dr. evil laughs that's
yeah let me see the wives check your
husband's you see the ability to turn
off and forming the ability to turn on
right I mean you see this in athletics
all the time meaning the the someone's
capacity to turn off and relax being
directly correlated to their ability to
turn it on if they're always on or
somewhere in the middle it just doesn't
seem to manifest the same way I remember
hearing this story about gent named
marcelo garcia so he's considered sort
of the michael jordan mike tyson Wayne
Gretzky combined of the Brazilian
jiu-jitsu or at least something like a
nine time world champion and I know a
fellow who co-owns a school of him and
Marcelo has gone to the World
Championships biggest event of the year
on the planet and he's supposed to go
into the finals and they call his name
to go out to the mat and he's asleep and
the bleachers they had to go shake him
to wake him up needs to groggy rubbing
his eyes walks out and then as soon as
he steps on the mat just different
person
I totally endorsed that you get
self into a state of calmness and the
ferocity will take care of itself
I had a similar thing out the other day
I wasn't playing in Seattle with the
Seattle you know Symphony they're doing
Ben Hur it's a 90-minute program with
big orchestra really complex show my
hotel rooms just around the corner so I
go back after you know a rehearsal time
and I set my alarm for 6 o'clock and I
got into a sneeze I said it for 6 a.m.
not p.m. oh so I wake up oh like that
and I got a bit of a sandwich there and
I'm chewing on the sandwich and I look
oh [ __ ] I run you know oh god oh god oh
god oh god the elevator and I'm on the
28th for elevator out of service down
the step get there like that okay show
time best show ever
[Applause]
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by kettle and
Fire which makes some of the best bone
broth and certainly the most convenient
that I've ever found and I have a big
stack of them on my kitchen counter
right now I have one container every
morning and this first came highly
recommended to me by past podcast guests
such as Amelia Boone who's a four-time
world champion and world stops mutter
Spartan Race etcetera and dr. Dominic
D'Agostino The Incredible Hulk of
scientific research should check him out
too but there are a few things that make
kettle and fire special number one they
are the first shelf stable in other
words never frozen bone broth that uses
bones from 100% grass-fed organically
raised animals so you are what you eat
eight if that makes sense
so it's very important that you
understand if you're consuming animal
protein what they consume they also use
longer cook times 20 plus hours which
means more collagen and other nutrients
for instance they contain 19 times more
collagen than one of their close
competitors and an independent lab
confirm this
I'll leave the
competitors name out of it because I
don't want to get sued but that's the
case and it is not frozen so thanks to
many millions of dollars of packaging
equipment their bone broth doesn't
require freezing or shipping with dry
ice so like I said it's just sitting on
my kitchen counter in these boxes and
then I can keep them up there basically
ready to drink
keep them up on stovetop or in a
microwave and you are ready to rock and
roll and you also get a nice payload of
glucosamine glycine along with the
gelatin and everything else that I
mentioned so check it out
I have been hugely pleased with this and
like I said have been consuming it every
morning it gives you about let's say 20
grams of protein which is a nice little
slow carb diet' boost if that's what
you're looking for and I'll typically
sift this up a very large camping coffee
mug as I do some writing or journal so
there you have it check it out it's
delicious I favor the chicken but each
to his own or her own so check it out
Hetal and feiyr.com forward slash to him
and you can receive 20% off of your
entire order take a look kettle and
feiyr.com forward slash tip it is very
late at night I am packing for an island
getaway why does that matter because it
reminds me of one of the sponsors for
today's podcast
Mizanin man why because the only dress
shirt that I'm taking I normally hate
dress shirts is from mizzen and Maine
specifically the Beckett
blue gingham the reason are the reasons
I should say is because I can throw it
in my bag in a duffel not worry about
ironing not worry about any kind of
wrinkling and then throw it on where it
maybe four or five nights out of seven
without washing it it won't smell
antimicrobial it is made of stretch
fabric sweat wicking athletic I could
wear for a hike in between tanners if I
want to do it probably wouldn't do that
but mizzen and Maine has really
delivered on the all-around all-purpose
dress shirt they're fancy enough you can
fool people into thinking that you had
them custom tailored but they're also
rough enough and resilient enough that
you can toss them into the bottom
a duffel bag or backpack pull it off and
put it on in a bathroom at a restaurant
let's say hundreds of pro athletes love
this brand people who don't fit well and
shirts otherwise like NFL offer of JJ
Watt and the last time these guys were
featured on the show the domain sold out
of every item that they featured so if
you're interested in checking them out I
had to recommend taking a look just go
to Tim vlog forward slash shirts and you
can see that one shirt that I'm packing
then I always pack the Becket blue
gingham in addition to a couple of my
other favorites and you can enter Tim
that's capital T I am at checkout for
free shipping if you use this code
before September 15th its 2017 to buy a
dress shirt Mizanin main will donate a
brand new dress shirt to the relief
efforts in southern Texas that's in
addition to the thousand shirts that are
already being donated through JJ Watts
incredible efforts to put our I should
say weather help Houston and the
surrounding communities get back on
their feet so there you have it
check it out take a look even if it's
just to take a peek at this one shirt
the Becket Tim blog forward slash shirts
again that's Tim dot blog forward slash
shirts
[Applause]